in Dadar university in century uganda
provides meals to 1,800 students every
day and uses huge amounts of cooking
wood in the process the university is
looking to change that with the help of
the German engineer our bread Smith is
working with the Energy Research Center
to replace wood with more sustainable
briquettes made from corn waste the
first new stove is already in operation
it was a former firewood stove and we
adapted it to the briquette we are
already planning to adapt another stove
for briquette to briquette and one by
one will be replaced I think the
university hopes to radically reduce its
wood consumption Uganda has a huge
problem with the frustration every year
ninety thousand hectares of forests are
lost in the country much of the word is
used to cook food most of the
institutions talk about schools talk
about prisons talk about universities
they use a lot and a lot of fuel for
cooking and many of the fuel that is
being used for cooking is the firewood
and where they cut fees and you know
this is not and sustainable any more so
we started thinking can it be able to to
apply briquettes on an institutional
level the university gets the materials
for its briquettes from local farmers
who grow corn also known as maize we
take them is only the cops we just throw
in the cutting or we just leave it there
wrote the good 3020 the people came they
are twisty giving us some money and they
give today the cops
Albert Smits has persuaded the farmers
to collect the cobs rather than throwing
them away the three large sacks each
farmer receives the equivalent of one
u.s. dollar it's a welcome source of
extra income for the small-scale farmers
who often struggle financially the Cubs
are dried at a small factory then placed
in a cabin either for two days it turns
them into charcoal they're then mixed
with water and molded into briquettes
these are left to dry in the Sun for
another five days then they're ready for
use the factory produces a ton of
briquettes each week that's nowhere near
enough we cannot produce much more and
we calculated to replace all the
firewood of our university kitchen and
this school we provide with briquette we
need around photons per week so we have
to build another bigger carbon I thought
since starting to produce briquettes the
university has massively cut back on a
firewood use that's not only helping to
preserve the forest it's also serving
the institution money and the idea is
catching on a nearby school has now also
introduced a new technology Albert Smith
is hoping the project will set a
precedence nationwide and help stop the
rapid disappearance of Uganda's forests